hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to golfing over it with Alva
ma hole now this is a shameless rip I
will be the first to admit it it is
probably an absolute shameless rip or
copy of getting over it with Bennett
foggy even the name suggests that it's
trying to emulate it as closely as
possible now does that mean that that
matters depends on who you ask but what
does matter is people probably do say or
think or are sure of that this game is
infuriating but probably not for the
same reasons considering I'm going to be
golfing up a mountain instead of not
getting up a mountain at all and
screaming and rage don't expect me to
get super duper angry on this one I'm
probably gonna stay as calm as possible
because I doubt that I'm actually going
to be taking this so seriously that it
actually makes me mad but we will see
upon the first whatever I'm doing mmm I
hate that already okay that's not so bad
I've seen videos of this not the top of
it but you can hit it you can hit it
while it's in midair which is probably
not gonna be the most considerably good
thing okay so you can't hit it when it
starting over oh my god it's going to be
deeply frustrating the frustration for
this appointment if you are willing to
admit that the mistake was yours
but the feeling will only get more
intense the longer you play you're going
to want to keep playing and everything
you don't every time you find the
strength to keep going right okay and if
you manage to get to the top it's all
been worth it I think you will you don't
know that about me and I don't know that
about you so don't assume anything of me
and I won't zoom anything of you can I
already say that I don't like your voice
sounds like you're too close in my ear
for my comfort
uh-huh okay so so far not so bad it's
it's really not the worst thing I've
ever done in the world if your progress
will be saved automatically
okay all right sure whatever you say
you're not Bennett fatty and frankly
that's a good thing okay not so badly
no so bad oh not so bad as far as I can
say it does that same thing with the
controls where the old boy do I have to
get on top of this shovel to be able to
get up here
there's no way in hell that I'm gonna be
able to do that
oh oh ah so the longer you the longer
you hold it after you've been hit the
bigger the circle charges oh oh hey not
so bad not so bad that's that's worse
[Music]
the time as the father of inflationary
bad controls we're responsive and hard
to understand intentionally bad controls
are bad in the sense that they are
suboptimal for the task at hand making a
challenging and infuriating experience
what other high school will be a walk in
the park and yet they often make for
amusing games huh your task is simply to
climb up a mountain the dragging
yourself with a hammer while sitting
inside the cauldron no amount of forward
progress is going to eat some cliffs our
cashier or two sleepily lady is in
constant danger of falling and losing
everything
yeah I watched a video of an Atari
playing his own game and it was
interesting to see how rapidly he
approached at his own challenges he
never was possible to overcome them and
he knew the movements he needed to
execute so he will make an attempt but
he will fail without a clear reason why
so he will drag in exactly the same
movements he attempted the first time
and he will repeat this process until
eventually yeah oh no the
both buddy a little bit of both also
it's an interesting perspective - oh
[ __ ] hell it's an interesting
perspective just that okay interesting
perspective just to have like the the
dialogue mimic the exact dialogue from
the beginning of the getting over it
with Bennett FUBU it's not that bad like
I get it this this beginning is gonna be
rough for me because I'm learning the
capabilities of what I can do but that
doesn't mean that doesn't mean that it's
both that doesn't mean [ __ ] you that
doesn't mean that it's bad it just me
[ __ ] you it just means that it's
annoying there we go just light taps
sometimes you need a hard tap sometimes
you just need a light et/pt tap there
you know there you go yeah just the
lightest of hooches oh dang get up there
oh yeah see how good no oh no I'm
learning it though I am in fact learning
it because it's getting better it's it's
the double the double maybe there's a
triple hit possible do you think that's
a thing I mean as long as it's white
right oh yes yes baby you can nope not
like that oh my god oh my god hey okay
we've made it back up here finally ha
okay alright but it's okay because we're
trying to make it up here new very close
getting good getting better
I just can't bounce there too hard haha
the triple jump oh baby a triple let me
try to just get up on this racket just
oh just a little up on the racket is all
I really need because if I can get up on
the racket that's where I probably
should be if I wanted to make the jump
more precisely oh yeah okay so when we
go here oh no okay I almost did the
exact same thing that I did last time
but not this time
because I'm not an idiot
okay this is this is fun
very scary
okay ha ha ha yeah yeah yeah okay OOP
wink drunk oh nice hair nice anime hair
OOP no oh oh my god you're very scary Oh
what no no no no no no no no blaming
frustration may be essential to having a
real challenge an obstacle that you are
not volunteered to be able to overcome
Duty actor friend in itself can be
enjoyable blending and getting over it
is not escaping because you can easily
fall down and lose all your progress
because controlling the main character
is of course the worst part is not that
you have to play Miguel over again is
that you have to fight with the controls
when doing so this game is pretty
misallocating nobody you need to climb
up a wall make up to me the point of the
game is built around the fact that it's
a very hard challenge and you can easily
lose all your progress at any time
the main difference will make this game
more than just a clone of the original
this is controlled not only because
hitting a wall is quite different from
calling your server because it's easy to
control you hit the wall with a certain
force at a certain angle and that's it
the difficulty lies in calculating what
force on what angle you should apply to
the ball and it's nothing creating
because you feel in control if the ball
doesn't land where you want it no no no
now you feel that you can do it better
if you try again this is a game in which
you can experience the challenge of
climbing no no no no no no no we're
finishing this is gonna be a son of a
[ __ ] and I agree with that the controls
you know it's it's it's not unknowable
it's it's predictable
it is he is absolutely right you just
got a touch it with the right scooch and
you've got magic happening you've got
magic shooting out of your ball you just
need you just need the tucci scooch it
just the right way I got a
scoochie touch up there I got a Tootsie
scooch up there I got a two cheese
scooch up there
I've got no I've got two Tucci scooch up
there I've got two two cheese scooch up
there no oh good perfect touch what hey
look at me yeah Oh skill wheeze kiwis
skew II hope no oh my god I'm on the
eagle I just got a good on the low fat
oh my god no no no no no no no oh no no
no oh shut the [ __ ] oh [ __ ] off somehow
he's more annoying I don't know how he's
managed to do it but somehow he's way
he's been able to come up with a way to
talkin to me that's just even more
infuriating than Bennett fought he ever
could have been
who the act of pulling it back each time
after each subsequent one is quite
difficult cuz it's like I don't pull
enough maybe I don't need to pull it
much at all I guess I don't right it's
it's not about pulling yeah okay it's -
it's not about how hard you pull it
right yeah it's not it was I was misled
into thinking that you'd have to pull it
back harder it's just it's only based in
time yeah no no no yes yes yes oh this
is like golf with your friends all over
again except it's even worse no no oh my
god no oh no no no God [ __ ] a donkey
damn it what's over here is there
anything over here just a goddamn tree
is that what it is is that where we're
dealing with what happens if I go over
there god
damn tree huh why do I want to go this
tree I'm not sure up what is this what
is what is what the [ __ ] is this what is
this what am I looking at some kind of
giant oh it's like a tornado dick
whatever it is I don't care all right
let's go back up let's go back up the
other way yeah yeah the thing is like
it's easy to just like in golf it's very
easy to do are necessary um oh man
force force is the word I was looking
for it's very easy to apply unnecessary
force oh no no okay it's not so bad
that's not as bad as going all the way
down cuz I mean I can predictably get
bad nope no no god [ __ ] a ducky I didn't
do it right click goes to that okay easy
shot yeah just got a fall in the pocket
that's all I gotta do just like on that
elephant I just got to not overshoot it
fall in the tusks like a gentle summer
breeze and now I just got a fall on the
tail thing I've ever even better even
look they're touching hmm they're
touching I went too far
oh I love all of your hair it's so
pretty even you Naruto
oh my god where am i oh I don't like the
underwater nests of this please tell me
that I can't please tell me that on a
rare occasion I won't be falling through
that little gap there that's something
that I would like very much okay just
gotta get in the doochie scooches yeah
oh so safe Dora
new parquet all right
I was caught no oh my god okay I was
caught there we go
just got a yeah like like a summer
breeze doing it oh god I'm in it okay oh
there's the I guess this is land sea
level and that's okay didn't God made a
lot of progress in a very shrewd ooh
very short amount of time why are you
still moving okay uh uh why did you go
that way
oh the little the little divet rivet on
the boat that's fun that that is there
okay all right easy peasy there no no
where are you going on the destination
we in the Jordan if you let go of the
idea of reaching the top you will enjoy
this game a lot more it will be a
relaxing experience I'm falling without
any car sure you will
you don't know that I don't even care
about the top of the mountain I am just
playing I am NOT I'm not concerned about
getting to the top of the mountain
that's not my concern do you think
that's my concern my concern is trying
to beat this game with my sanity intact
why nope nope nope okay back on the
horse again
hahaha I'm sure that's what it's really
supposed to be
[Music]
any [ __ ] day now any [ __ ] day no
no no no no no why would you do that
just stop rolling [ __ ] stuff oh my
God if you ice white swear to [ __ ] oh
my god
are you [ __ ] kidding me oh my god
oh my god I can't get up this now Oh
what I can't get up this this I can't
get up this oh my god
it doesn't matter what I do it's light
or hard I can't get up this this always
happens every single [ __ ] time I play
any sort of difficulty any game period
if I do any [ __ ] game it starts out
totally fine I'm fine everything's
everything starts out totally [ __ ]
fine and then for some reason skill just
goes completely out the window
nice nice nice okay I'm back in the
saddle uh-oh
again I'm back in the saddle again
among my people
that's so scary I know that's a safe
spot but I don't trust that to always be
a safe spot for some reason for some
reason because I know how games liked a
dick I have this weird feeling that it's
gonna suddenly decide on a random sure
[Music]
yes right in the pocket okay just like
that baby just like that
careful careful now care
careful careful now careful now okay
okay okay let's just go no no please
[Music]
let's just go back i bail i bail i bill
i bill I bail bail bail I bail I don't
care what's new playing silently wishing
for you to make it to the top I really
don't care because there's a kind of
pointing at her and if you touch it you
will fire like I said I I don't care
there's a cannon pointed at her well
then that seems like it's her fault for
living in a oh well you know I'm a touch
toucan and I'm I'm really gonna touch
that cannon so sorry sorry albatross oh
well poor albatross poor Alvie oh oh
well that's too bad that looks like it
could be bad the spikes there look like
Bad News Bears
ah so why did they make this game I
don't know man lying in bed thinking of
an initial concept for a golf game we
had nothing to do with this one except
for the fact that it will be challenging
and potentially frustrating uh-huh
I was considering a pass-through station
will be similar to that of getting over
and then a title just popped up in my
mind
nothing already without oh no no I'm in
unquestionably uncomf-- territory right
now and I don't do I have to like you
that seems scary that seems really scary
but I'll know or I'm not cut out for
this thank you is that the ghost of
Alvarez you came to save me okay I don't
know no no no no no why no okay this is
this is scoot yeah you know let's just
go right there that's perfectly fine
no no no no no no no no no no it won't
save me twice I told you those spikes
were bad news it's all - those spikes
were bad news okay gently oh yeah
nope no no no no no
thank you thank you for that
for [ __ ] sake no no that's gonna go
all the way down
good [ __ ] God good [ __ ] God oh
that's going all the way I can't get on
this horse anymore I just can't I can't
get on the horse again for some reason I
can't get on the horse I remember before
I was able to get on the horse totally
fine
but somehow that's all gonna this is
gonna roll for [ __ ] ever
I hate this there's there's a legitimate
reason why I can't do raids games is it
like it doesn't just make me angry it
makes me so [ __ ] miserable it's not
just anger it's just misery it's pain
it's painful for me to do this it's an
itchy all over body feeling to do these
games it just makes everything
uncomfortable and then four hours for
hours and hours and hours afterwards I
can't do anything and the worst part is
because I don't like to give up because
I don't ever like to give up I just keep
[ __ ] doing it it's it's a vicious
cycle that feeds in in it it's not
something that I do because oh [ __ ] yeah
I a rage game people can laugh at me
being angry [ __ ] that what have I ever
done anything like that for your benefit
it's just it's a [ __ ] blow I want to
be very [ __ ] clear about this this is
not about you this is not about you this
is not about you at all this is nothing
to do with you this is not a goddamn
thing to do with you I'm the one who
wants to beat it I am the one who wants
to make progress I am the one who is
upset because I am learning about this
game and it's not
this [ __ ] somehow we've made it back
up here not 100% sure how but I'm not
gonna question it in the corner pocket
no no please please oh my god all right
let's just do this nice and easy style
no pressure no pressure no pressure this
is not that difficult
okay that's fine no pressure no no no no
no no oh my god oh good thing I went for
the the extra power okay I don't
understand why those were big no no some
of those shots were bigger but they were
real quick and I I'm not sure I'm far no
no no [ __ ] oh thank you I guess
thank you I guess thank you I guess I
guess no no no god [ __ ] damnit oh no
no no no no oh my god no no no God oh I
can't do this Oh nope that's that's all
the way that's all the way that's
News Update
it stopped making me angry cuz I just
don't care anymore what the [ __ ] does it
matter we're all gonna die anyway so
[ __ ] love this this is my favorite
thing to do yeah
this is how I wanted to spend my day
yeah there we go no yeah no that's great
fun okay
hit the ceiling no here we go again yay
yay yay yay whoo
can you believe how much fun I'm having
whoa whoa whoa someone stop me someone
call the fun police I'm just having too
much of a good thing oh boy I'm so happy
to be alive oh man I'm glad I was born
in this year where this game was made
and I get to play it can you see how
lucky I am yay yay oh boy yeah yeah
wahoo
now I know why Mario shouts wahoo
[Applause]
there we go just bypassed the horse just
completely no never mind
again oh well great great great great
great [ __ ] great a gig again ago well
just don't even bother don't even bother
it doesn't [ __ ] matter cuz every oh I
did it again okay good why are you oh my
god you don't release sometimes it just
doesn't release it just doesn't it
didn't see it didn't there it didn't
release it why didn't you release it
stop stop just oh no no oh no uh there
that's not bad that's pretty good
actually
okay all right I don't know what it
wants from me but we've made forward
progress which is a goddamn delight oh
now you're gonna start talking to me
okay which way am I going here am I
trying to get in the little scooch I
hate having to repeat a part of a video
game over and over until I committed
philosophy so why did I make this game
the truth is it was an accident
like an unplanned pregnancy after coming
up with the title
I wanted to pet the concept just to see
what it will feel like I created the
ball and the controls then I started
building and testing the world and it
was fun it was so much fun I got into a
deeper state of flow I worked all day
forgetting to eat not wanted to sleep I
did the thing that I after and the one
after that and before I knew it the body
of the game was finished I will have
never planned to make a dream like this
even if we forget my design principles
for a moment I would have never made a
game that leaves only a shadow of
another one it feels cheap no it doesn't
reflect well on us and at least yet I
call them big water stop them to delete
the game and move on I felt like this
game deserves to be made in the end I
decided to embrace this fate I will
finish making this frustrating game and
I will make it all about this
relationship to getting over it like an
unofficial espírito sequence I just
completely bypassed it because I didn't
want to deal with it
okay easy enough just got to get in the
butt crack of the planets here looks
like we can actually avoid it which is
nice don't know what's up with the DNA
you know what this looks like it's going
to be a son of a [ __ ] how in the hell
oh I see we're just supposed to go
around it we're not supposed to be
looking at it okay I don't know oh
that's the inner workings of a cell okay
I have a funny feeling it's getting too
dicey moments but I want to try to get
up on that cell and I know I can do that
yep I knew I could do it easy enough
this actually isn't all that hard
this actually is surprisingly easy mmm
don't prove me wrong okay I just got a
go too much too much cool scooch too
much no oh my god oh my god oh my god
mm-hmm okay I gotta be careful I'm I'm
liable to lose everything if I get cocky
which I have a habit of doing at the
worst of times okay all right that's
easy enough I'm on a Skellington which
is nice I don't know where I am in the
grand scheme do you have hair as well oh
you do you do in a friend part of a
friend anyway all right so this isn't
the worst thing in the world
oh no no no no no no no only rose to the
top now you must have suffered a lot to
get here not as much as you think even
the tents would you choose to make
things easier for yourself or will you
choose to suffer even more no this is
yours there's no reward for choosing one
or the other except for the rewarding
feelings you may experience for
overcoming or avoiding an extra bit of
challenge I don't care what you have to
say philosophically wise so that left is
harder and right is easier well that's
got to be a goddamn trick
oh well speaking of tricks so I'm gonna
go the harder path just because I'm
pretty sure that's what they would want
to send you down anyway so kudos to me I
guess
see I know is this it no okay you know
what not playing that [ __ ] game you
know what you want to play disappearing
blocks with me [ __ ] you [ __ ] you in
every possible way shape and form
hey I've triggered the music those
that's nice I guess yeah screw that [ __ ]
I'm not going there not doing that not
going there not doing that not going
there oh no oh boy okay be careful with
this one
easy enough these these these blocks
seem slanted which generally means that
I would roll off either side they don't
seem straight up flat just a cursory
observation tells me that if I land on
it wrong I'm probably going to you know
end up dying
no no no no no come on
oh [ __ ] me oh no well this is welcome to
the new hell just a short stop away from
the old hell nope why did I do that
I don't know I have no idea why I do
anything in this game I don't even know
why I'm still playing this [ __ ] game
no [ __ ] come I don't this is this
this is what you saved me at this is
this is okay whatever you know what
thank you I guess
okay and you're not gonna it's which
direction are you gonna go in okay
that's fair
it bugs if you click it too fast which
is so [ __ ] great
mother [ __ ] you didn't go which way
are you gonna go Oh God nope okay oh wow
you know what I am grateful for that but
I was actually looking forward to just
being able to say goodbye to this game I
really was so frankly you didn't save me
from anything you just made me have to
keep which direction are we gonna go in
yep that's what I [ __ ] thought you
[ __ ] buggy piece of [ __ ] I was gonna
be able to say goodbye and that would
have been really great because I wanted
to go on with my life but no I'm still
[ __ ] playing give me a [ __ ] excuse
to stop this stupid asinine game okay I
don't know where we are and I don't know
why but I'm just gonna count my
blessings and assume that I'm getting
close to the end because I have got to
hey moon you're gonna open your eye when
I least suspect it probably yeah Wow
good yeah I can go hi I know how to do
the trick
yep I sure do I sure should do wow that
was I even I didn't think I was gonna
make that oh good golf I know that's not
how we do it here god [ __ ] damn it
this is where it's gonna get real dicey
isn't it yep okay Wow I'm here what is
here why does this matter
thank you
I'm a hero that sounds sarcastic
when tone sounds really sarcastic and I
don't appreciate the sarcasm nope this
is not what I wanted
okay I'll take it don't [ __ ]
I hate you all right what have we got
here
oh is this actually the end or is this
just a trick is this a is this the end
is it what is this what is this how are
you gonna screw me over is the only
question I have in my mind Oh what
happens if I go over it okay or you're
not even you're not even gonna give me
the chance to okay I wanted yeah
whatever I don't think you can get over
and frankly I don't care all right I
didn't even see what my stats were
because I was trying to do something
else but oh well I'm done yay an hour
and 36 minutes 2898 hits I started
getting really good at the game I really
did I started getting good at that game
I don't like that no I don't like that
I'm good at this game but that's fine
yeah it really was it was one of those
situations where I was playing I was
playing I was playing I got mad and
frustrated and then like something just
dropped out of me and I realized I just
didn't care I didn't care I didn't care
I didn't want to beat it and I felt a
sense of calm as I was just trying to
get through the [ __ ] game but I did
it and I did it and the thing is it's
not a bad game it's not bad it's I don't
know it's it's obviously derivative
because it was obviously inspired by
getting over it so inherently it gets
some points deducted for being a less
than original idea but the golfing
aspect of it does bring some different
difficulty to it even if the mechanics
are still kind of [ __ ] but that is
that I don't like it I don't like
anything about it I hate this game with
a fiery burning passion and that is all
I have to
say about that so thank you everybody so
much for watching let me know what you
thought of this down in the comments
below if you didn't know I am going on
tour in Amsterdam in July and there are
just some tickets left so go to tor dom
markiplier comm and check him out for
yourself also in November we're coming
to Australia first shows in New Zealand
I believe go to tour da markiplier comm
or click on the link in the description
below and you can see for yourself so
thank you again and as always I will see
you
[Music]